From the event we hope to get an innedit
level of action in Argentina, given its dimensions.
Argentina has lots of experience with hackathons
and in getting developers, and being able to
generate new ideas and to work in a communitarian way.
The developer community of Argentina is
more than interesting and, above all, with the possibility
to share and work on
that allow us to get a bigger amount of knowledge
and that will allow us to innovate
as well as new applications that can be use socially or
to grow the developer community and productive of
Argentina. In this case,
by its dimensions, we'll be faced with a event
with no predecesor, at least
in what I can remember. A developer,
to be successful, at the very least should
count with two fundamental characteristics,
one is that he/she must know how to integrate gadgets
and programming; and second, he/she must be able to read
the need in his/her community
to transform it into a viable, intelligent, and
interesting solution; and above all
usable. The most important thing to have a
successful app, is to have somebody incorporate it as
their own, for the app to be used and offer a solution
to a problem. The Google
tools, have in my opinion as a fundamental characteristic to have shown... In reality these are
platforms that have shown us how to work collaboratively.
We should never forget that
before Google Maps, it was very hard that by using a single platform
information could be aggregated, say, in a way
so simple and useful; and that you could
see how that information, produces new knowledge,
with the possibility to increase thtat idea
that the space-time, that place, that topology
being shown in the map can be aggregated
of a bunch of information on technological device.
We invite you!
I give a +1 to the Developer Bus!.